اذا هزه ارتداديه جديده في نفس المكان في
مركز الزلزال حيث انت
قربنا اكثر من المشهد
نعم
الهزات
الارتداديه لم تتوقف يعني هناك اكثر من
130 هزه ارتداديه حصلت في
منطقه الزلزال وخصوصا في منطقه بازار
بازار تشيك التي هي مركز الزلزال التي
تبعد من هنا حوالي عشره كيلو متر من وسط
كهرمان مرش
المنطقه لا زالت والتحذيرات التي تاتي من
السلطات خصوصا من اداره الكوارث والطوارئ
التركيه تتحدث عن اخذ الحيطه والحذر نحن
نشاهد المواطنين لا يزالون في الشوارع في
معظم المدن ليس فقط في كهرمان مرش معظم
المدن التركيه البلدات العشره التي تعرضت
للكارثه الزلزال
طلبت منهم السلطات التركيه عدم العوده
منازلهم الى البنايات خصوصا ان هناك
الكثير من البنايات التي تعرضت الى تصدع
ودمار جزئي هذه مهدده بالانهيار اذا ما
حصلت هزه ارتداديه
كما اشارت السلطات التركيه ان الهزات
الاستداديه بعضها وصل الى
6.46.7 وهي
زلازل بحد ذاتها زلازل قويه جدا كما اشار
الرئيس التركي الى ان المنطقه تعرضت الى
زلزالين ليست الى هزه ارتداديه اخرى كما
اشير في اليوم الاول للزلزال وانما تعرضت
الى زلزالين زلزال
فاصل 7.7 وزلزال سبعه فاصله سته في نفس
المنطقه التي حدثت